pop action is a form that I and Streb
you know the larger strap which is
pretty much hundreds and hundreds of
dancers at this point have been
developing over the last thirty years if
we were just never been kind of crazy
set of action aficionado x' it would be
similar to parkour but because I was in
the dance world and located myself in
the early 70s in the downtown
experimental postmodern dance world I
placed a very formal lens over my
investigations the simple idea about pop
action was I believed that humans could
fly the genesis of the whole idea began
by me awkwardly leaping off ladders and
crashing to the floor I didn't realize
how complicated it would be and how much
Hardware I'd need and how impractical it
is to fly you know on every level so I
started really low to the ground it was
also a theatrical artistic suspicion
that I thought no one lands like it's
not just flight it's a failure of flight
like the dance world doesn't ever land
I've spent a lot of technical time
camouflaging gravity the circus never
lands they just swing it's beautiful
aesthetic but there's no rhythm in
swinging they don't land either
gymnastics doesn't land the only maybe
football in an American boxing deals
with impact so I early on started to
develop a technique for taking the hit
when we landed and I think that the
drama of action theater is really
embedded in that moment but I think
flight flips things that different
acrobats do but weren't considered
elitist moments in time and space and
body actually are the most exciting
moves a human can do and notice that and
I wanted to embed it into my my action
scenario more so it wasn't just flight
it was how you fly and that you land if
you examine normal dance and their base
of support is usually the bottoms of
their feet we shift our base of support
a couple formal principles here in pop
action are just shifting your base of
support and from the bottoms of your
feet which put you in
to normal pedestrian spatial locality
and maybe landing on your stomach
landing on your back landing on your
shins landing on your side landing on
your shoulders so that you really Reese
Culp the occupational space the body is
in and therefore provide a different
point of view or vantage point to the
audience and then also believed after
the Muybridge plates on human movement
potential and animal movement potential
that I wanted to remove all transitions
all predictive acts so the plie you do
when you're going to jump and I'm not
interested theatrically and showing the
audience my preparation or my recovery
so it just went down being in on
habitual places in space encountering
danger inhabiting force fields because I
believe that the action experience
artistically had to be for the audience
a kinesthetic experience not a
storytelling idea gravity is our friend
you know it's many people's you know
it's an aberration to them it's
something that they avoid at all costs
do not fall down we strap really
believes that gravity is the most
exciting force on earth it's oddly
enough out of all the four forces the
weakest and yeah if you hurl your body
out a foot off the ground only or even
three feet and then you just let it land
perfectly horizontally you'll get a wall
up that you just can't imagine and I
could invite all your audience to just
try it you know first on your mattress
in your bedroom and then go ahead and do
it on the carpeted floor but you have to
stay perfectly horizontal I think that
gravity is where the content of
theatrical action resides I think that
that's what the drama is it shows the
danger it shows the force of our world
it shows bravery of the dancers and I
think that it's a metaphor also that if
you can do that and keep getting up and
do it again it somehow magically spreads
a message that you're willing to let
that happen to your body we're more
privileged people people that tend to be
in higher classes keep harm
very very very far away from them and
we're basically letting harm come right
into our body into our core puzzles and
I think that the metaphor that that
contains and and and and transfers to
anybody witnessing in allows them to
think I could go just a little bit
further I could do just a little bit
more I could be just a little bit braver